at the end of World War two the Soviets
were holding Berlin under siege in order
to save millions of people from
starvation the US and allies devised a
plan to airlift in food one American
pilot decided to take it a step further
he delivered candy my name is Gail
Halvorsen but I'm known as the Berlin
candy bomber
I didn't think when he left the last
very long so I thought I'd better get
movie of this operation before they send
me home
one day while filming the planes taking
off and landing Gale became aware that
there was some young children watching
him he went over to talk to them and
after a while he realized dummy don't
you know kids like chocolate and I knew
that then I had chocolate the stores in
Berlin for two years and I rishis my
pocketknife all I had was two sticks of
Wrigley's Doublemint gum I broke through
six and a half gave kids and the kids
will have a steak tore off the wrapper
the thin strips and passed it to those a
lot gone those who received the wrappers
put it up their nose and smelled a piece
of wrapper
inspired by their generosity he decided
that next flight he would drop them
chocolate and candy by a parachute from
the plane they said how do we know
whatever playing you're in and so I said
when I come over the airfield a wiggle
owns that big aeroplane this old green
Trudy is word the next day Gail began to
drop the packages what started with just
two sticks of gum eventually turned into
23 tons of chocolate from then on as
normal a person all the kids in Berlin
that's not believe me wings and in case
you are wondering if the candy bomber
still has a sweet tooth oh yeah
I still eat chocolate I like doctor